[Music]
baby you're my shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
ben affleck is back on screen with his
lady love jennifer lopez nearly two
decades after starring in the singer's
jenny from the block music video you
know this one
[Music]
now ben doesn't fully appear in the new
video for the ballad version of marry me
like he did back then i have no
explanation for that this time around
it's a lot more subtle baby you're my
shelter
shelter from a broken paradise
i couldn't dream it any better if i
tried
yup that's bennefer 2.0 together in bed
goofing around and cuddling and at one
point j lo reaches out her hand to him
it just turned out to be something
really magical but this isn't the first
time ben showed his support for jen's
work give her a kiss man
last month at the marry me premiere the
two didn't shy away from showing off
some pda
this is just a good date night it's a
great date night we're super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't really realize
how big
well the couple may not be too far away
from taking that next step nearly a year
since rekindling their romance a source
told e.t in february that ben and jayla
are open to the possibility of getting
engaged and married i've heard you say
so many times that you are a hopeless
romantic and you still believe in love
you believe in marriage so like cat you
still believe in all of this absolutely
why wouldn't i
the source says that jen feels their
love story is like a fairy tale like
they're meant to be quote she is so
incredibly in love with him ben is so
funny and confident he's always telling
jen she can do anything he is not scared
or intimidated by her money or success
it's really
about
recognizing your own value and if that
next step happens soon the wedding
planner star knows what she wants i love
public displays of romance i don't know
that i would love a proposal i think
that that's a more intimate thing
between two people but i have no problem
with you know like pda like people say i
actually i'm all about it if you really
feel it but i um i do think that a
proposal is a kind of a a sacred
intimate thing that should just be
between two people um when you're about
to pledge your lives to each other
that's a big deal
[Music]
you